one two three  [Music]  one too many tries  [Music]  and i can't say i'm mine  [Music]  there's a snake in the middle of the  road  do i swerve to miss  [Music]  i can't shake this feeling that i hold  there's poison in your kiss  but i've got one too many ties to you  one too many tries for you i'm totally  down the mountainside for you and i  can't say i'm mine when love goes  [Music]  [Music]  three more hours my heart gets tossed i  can tumble down into the rocks my sleepy  eyes they start to cross  [Music]  do  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  your eyes are just like dynamite  still i ask for more cause i've got one  too many ties to you  one too many tries for you i'm totally  down i'm out inside for you and i can't  say i'm  [Music]  no i can't say i'm mine  [Music]  [Applause]  maybe